♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
AS OF RIGHT NOW, JOE BIDEN IS
THE STRONG FRONTRUNNER FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
NOMINATION.
ALMOST NOBODY SAW THAT COMING.
WE CERTAINLY DIDN’T.
AND WE APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
AGAIN AND AGAIN WE TOLD YOU JOE
BIDEN WOULD NEVER BE THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.
WE WERE WRONG.
HOW DID WE SCREW THAT UP?
MOSTLY BECAUSE WE DON’T THINK
LIKE DEMOCRATS THINK.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS A
COALITION OF BUSINESS INTERESTS
AND CONSERVATIVE IDEALOGUES.
AT ITS CORE IT’S ABOUT IDEAS.
THE CONSTITUTION, THE FREE
MARKET, THE BASIC PRINCIPLES OF
WESTERN CIVILIZATION.
DEMOCRATIC PARTY DON’T FIXATE ON
IDEAS THEIR BASE IS A
CONSTELLATION OF AGGRIEVED
INTEREST GROUPS HOSTILITY TO
TRADITIONAL AMERICANS.
MAY NOT HAVE MUCH IN COMMON BUT
UNITED IN THEIR DESIRE TO TAKE
POWER AND REDISTRIBUTE THE
SPOILS TO THEMSELVES.
TO ACHIEVE THAT DEMOCRATS KNOW
THEY MUST STICK TOGETHER, NO
MATTER WHAT.
GROUP COHESION IS THE ROOT OF
THEIR POWER.
ON THIS SHOW WE DIDN’T SEE IT
THAT WAY.
WE LOOKED AT THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY FIELD FROM THE OUTSIDE
AND WE THOUGHT THE OBVIOUS, IS
THIS PARTY REALLY GOING TO
NOMINATE A GUY WITH NO PROGRAM,
NO CORE BELIEFS AND BY THE WAY
WHO HAS CLEARLY LOST IT?
AND THE ANSWER WE LEARNED LAST
NIGHT IS, OF COURSE THEY ARE.
AND WHY WOULDN’T THEY?
IT MIGHT WORK.
BUT, HOLD ON, YOU ARE PROBABLY
WONDERING THE MOST BASIC
QUESTION OF ALL.
IF ELECTED PRESIDENT DO JOE
BIDEN REALLY OVERSEE THIS
COMPLEX NATION OF 320 MILLION
PEOPLE?
JUDGE FOR YOURSELF.
HERE IS BIDEN’S VICTORY SPEECH
FROM LAST NIGHT IN WHICH HE
MISTOOK HIS WIFE OF 43 YEARS FOR
HIS SISTER.
>> THEY DON’T CALL SUPER TUESDAY
FOR NOTHING.
[CHEERS]
BY THE WAY, THIS IS MY LITTLE
SISTER VALERIE AND I’M JILL’S
HUSBAND.
OH, NO.
THIS IS -- OH, YOU SWITCHED ON
ME.
THIS IS MY WIFE.
THIS IS MY SISTER.
THEY SWITCHED ON ME.
>> Tucker: SO APPARENTLY SOME
PRACTICAL JOKER HID HIS WIFE
FROM HIM.
CRUEL.
AS A MART FRIEND SAID LAST NIGHT
JOE BIDEN HAS TRYING TO SUCCEED
IN PRESIDENTIAL POLITICS.
AND HE HAS.
TOO BAD HE IS NOT THERE TO ENJOY
IT.
PRETTY FUNNY.
TO THE CYNICAL AND DARKLY CLEVER
PEOPLE BIDEN’S FADING INTELLECT
IS NOT A HANDICAP.
AN OPPORTUNITY.
JOE BIDEN IS WEAK AND IS HE
GETTING WEAKER.
ASK ANYONE WHO KNOWS HIM OR WHO
HAS WATCHED HIM CAREFULLY OVER
THE PAST 50 YEARS.
BIDEN IS NOTICEABLY MORE
CONFUSED NOW THAN HE WAS LAST
SPRING WHEN HE ENTERED THE RACE.
WHY IS THIS GOOD NEWS FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC ESTABLISHMENT IN
WASHINGTON?
WELL, BECAUSE IT MEANS THEY CAN
CONTROL HIM.
THAT’S ONE REASON THE OTHER
CANDIDATES WERE SO EAGER TO
SWING IN BEHIND BIDEN THE
INSTANT HE WON A STATE.
>> I AM ENDING MY CAMPAIGN AND
ENDORSING JOE BIDEN FOR
PRESIDENT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> I’M UNITING BEHIND THE
CANDIDATE WITH THE BEST SHOT TO
DO IT.
AND AFTER YESTERDAY’S VOTE, IT
IS CLEAR THAT CANDIDATE IS MY
FRIEND AND A GREAT AMERICAN, JOE
BIDEN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> I’M DELIGHTED TO ENDORSE AND
SUPPORT JOE BIDEN FOR PRESIDENT.
>>
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> I WILL BE CASTING MY BALLOT
FOR JOE BIDEN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: IT WASN’T JUST
DEMOCRATS WHO JUMPED ON BOARD.
THE ENTIRE SO-CALLED RESISTANCE,
ANGRY FORMER REPUBLICANS GOT IN
IMMEDIATELY, BILL CRYSTAL ANNA
NAVARRO, JENNIFER RUBIN THAT
WEIRD LITTLE GUY JEB BUSH’S
SPOKESMAN IN 2016.
THEY WERE ALL THRILLED BY
BIDEN’S RISE.
THEY KNOW BIDEN WILL GREEN LIGHT
POINTLESS WARS NO QUESTIONS
ASKED.
BECAUSE THE DAY COULDN’T GET
MORE PREDICTABLE AND HILARIOUS,
JAMES COMEY HIMSELF SENT A
SUPPORTIVE TWEET, QUOTE:  VOTED
IN FIRST DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY TO
SUPPORT A PARTY DEDICATED TO
RESTORING VALUES IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
I AGREE WITH AMY KLOBUCHAR, WE
NEED CANDIDATES WHO CARE ABOUT
ALL AMERICANS AND WILL RESTORE
DECENCY, DIGNITY TO THE OFFICE.
THERE IS A REASON TRUMP FEARS
JOE BIDEN AND ROOTS FOR BERNIE,
#BIDEN 2020.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE ARE HAPPY
FOR THE SAME REASON.
JOE BIDEN IS FADING AND
UNCERTAIN.
WEAK LEADERS ARE VESSELS FOR THE
STRONGER FORCES AROUND THEM AND
NO FORCE IN AMERICAN POLITICS IS
STRONGER, MORE AGGRESSIVE OR
BETTER ORGANIZED THAN THE NARROW
LITTLE INTEREST GROUPS THAT
COMPRISE THE DEMOCRATIC
COALITION.
THERE’S A REASON GOVERNOR RALPH
NORTHAM OF VIRGINIA SWUNG SO FAR
FROM THE CENTER AFTER HE WAS
CAUGHT WEARING CLAN ROBES.
HE WAS BADLY WOUNDED BY THAT ON
THE BRINK OF RESIGNING.
DEMOCRATIC INTEREST GROUPS
SWOOPED IN AND TOOK CONTROL OF
HIS ADMINISTRATION.
NOW THE NORTHAM ADMINISTRATION
LOOKS NOTHING LIKE IT ONCE DID.
THEY ARE IN CHARGE.
AS IF ON CUE, ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS JOE BIDEN DID AFTER
WINNING THE SOUTH CAROLINA
PRIMARY ON SATURDAY WAS PLEDGE
TO PUT BETO O’ROURKE IN CHARGE
OF HIS GUN POLICY.
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
JOE BIDEN.
>> I WANT TO MAKE SOMETHING
CLEAR, I’M GOING TO GUARANTEE
THIS IS NOT THE LAST YOU ARE
GOING TO SEE THIS GUY.
I WILL TAKE CARE OF THE GUN
PROBLEM WITH ME.
YOU WILL BE THE ONE WHO LEADS
THIS EFFORT.
I’M COUNTING ON YOU.
>> Tucker: BETO IS, QUOTE, GOING
TO TAKE CARE OF THE GUN PROBLEM.
HOW IS BETO GOING TO DO THAT?
O’ROURKE HAS PROMISED TO SEIZE
THE RIFLES OF LAW ABIDING
AMERICANS BY FORCE WITH ARMED
FEDERAL AGENTS IF NECESSARY.
THAT WASN’T A THROW AWAY LINE.
HE SAID IT REPEATEDLY.
THAT IS THE MOST EXTREME
POSITION ON GUN CONTROL EVER
ARTICULATED IN AMERICAN
POLITICS.
IT’S NOW JOE BIDEN’S POSITION
BECAUSE IT’S THE POSITION OF THE
POWERFUL DEMOCRATIC INTEREST
GROUPS THAT CONTROL HIM.
IN OTHER WORDS, DON’T EXPECT A
BIDEN PRESIDENCY TO BE MODERATE.
NOT BECAUSE JOE BIDEN HIMSELF IS
SOME CHILD EYED EXTREMIST.
HE IS A DAUGHTERRING OLD MAN WHO
GRINS A LOT.
BIDEN IS WILL MALLEABLE.
WHATEVER SURROUNDINGS FINDS
HIMSELF IN LIKE INCIDENT INCIDEN
CELEBRATE.
LIKE OLD COLONEL SANDERS GIVE
HIM A WHITE SUIT AND STRING TIE.
>> IF DEMOCRATS NOMINATE ME, I
BELIEVE I BELIEVE WE CAN BEAT
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Tucker: WE CAN BEAT DONALD
TRUMP.
THAT’S HOW THEY TALK IN
DELAWARE.
WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT IS A MAN
WILLING TO SAY VIRTUALLY
ANYTHING.
HARD EYED EXTREMIST IN THE PARTY
WILL USE BIDEN AS THEIR
INSTRUMENT ON THE FIRST DAY.
NOT JUST ON GUNS ON EVERY ISSUE.
IMMIGRATION, HEALTHCARE, TAXES,
JUDGES, ESOTERIC SOCIAL ISSUES
SO BIZARRE YOU DIDN’T KNOW THEY
EXISTED.
JOE BIDEN IS 77 YEARS OLD.
IF ELECTED, HE WOULD BE 78 ON
INAUGURATION DAY.
THAT’S ALMOST 10 YEARS OLDER
THAN RONALD REAGAN WAS WHEN HE
WAS FIRST SWORN.
IN BIDEN IS ACUTELY AWARE OF
THIS.
THAT’S WHY HE IS ALWAYS TALKING
ABOUT PUSHUPS AND CHALLENGING
OTHER MEN TO FIST FIGHTS.
HE IS INSECURE.
AND THAT INSECURITY MAKES BIDEN
SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE WORST PEOPLE
IN DEMOCRATIC POLITICS.
NOW, YOU MAY BE AFRAID OF THE
28-YEAR-OLD NIHILIST TRYING TO
REORDER AMERICAN SOCIETY AND YOU
SHOULD BE.
BUT JOE BIDEN IS ABSOLUTELY
TERRIFIED OF THEM.
HE DOESN’T UNDERSTAND EXACTLY
WHAT THEY ARE SAYING BUT HE
KNOWS THEY ARE THE FUTURE AND HE
IS NOT.
AND FOR THAT REASON HE IS
WILLING TO DO WHATEVER THEY ASK.
YOU CAN EXPECT TRANSGENDERED IS
A MONEYS WEEK TO BECOME A
FEDERAL HOLIDAY IN FIRST TERM
AND A WHOLE LOT MORE AFTER THAT.
BIDEN DOESN’T CARE ABOUT THE
DETAILS OF POLICY.
HE DOESN’T KNOW THE DIFFERENCE.
HE JUST DOESN’T WANT TO FALL
BEHIND.
WHAT ARE THE POLITICAL LESSONS
OF WHAT HAPPENED LAST NIGHT?
WELL, THE FIRST IS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC ESTABLISHMENT IS FAR
STRONGER THAN THE REPUBLICAN
ESTABLISHMENT.
NOT TO MENTION FAR BIGGER.
IT’S IN A DIFFERENT CATEGORY
FROM WHAT THE RIGHT HAS.
IT EXTENDS FAR BEYOND FOUR CABLE
NEWS SHOWS, A CLUSTER OF D.C.
THINK TANKS AND A FEW LOW
CIRCULATION MAGAZINES.
WE ARE ALMOST THROUGH THE FIRST
TERM OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
AND DEMOCRATS STILL OPERATE
VIRTUALLY EVERY LEVER IN OF
POWER IN THIS COUNTRY.
THEY CONTROL FINANCE, BIG
BUSINESS, THE TECH SECTOR, THE
NEWS MEDIA, OF COURSE, ACADEMIA,
THE VAST FEDERAL BUREAUCRACY AND
WE ARE INCLUDING IN THAT,
UNFORTUNATELY, THE PENTAGON AND
THE INTELLIGENCE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
EVERY POWER CENTER IN AMERICA IS
A RAID AGAINST DONALD TRUMP AND
WE WOULD ADD TO THAT LIST THE
GOVERNMENT OF COMMUNIST CHINA
WHICH WOULD BADLY LIKE TO RETURN
TO THE COMPLIANT AMERICAN
LEADERSHIP OF YESTERDAY.
ALL OF THESE GROUPS WILL BE
WORKING TIRELESSLY FOR JOE
BIDEN.
THEY WILL USE WHATEVER TOOLS
THEY POSSESS.
SOME OF THEM PUBLIC, MANY NOT.
ABOVE ALL, THEY WILL HAVE THE
MEDIA WHICH NEEDLESS TO SAY IS
ALREADY PLAYING ITS PRESCRIBED
ROLE.
>> WHAT A NIGHT IT’S BEEN FOR
JOE BIDEN.
WHAT A RACE IT’S BEEN.
I TOOK A NAP BECAUSE I KNEW I
WOULD BE UP LATE AND I WOKE UP
AND I THOUGHT I WAS STILL
DREAMING.
>> Tucker: IT WAS LIKE A DREAM.
LIKE A DREAM.
LIKE A BEAUTIFUL DREAM.
BY NOVEMBER THEY WILL BE TELLING
THAT YOU JOE BIDEN IS AN
INTERNATIONALLY RANKED CHESS
CHAMPION WHO CAN CURE BALDNESS.
MANY PEOPLE WILL BELIEVE THEM
BECAUSE THAT’S THE THING ABOUT
PROPAGANDA.
IT WORKS.
THAT’S WHY THEY DO IT.
REPUBLICANS SHOULD BE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS.
LOOK AT THE DEMOCRATIC TURNOUT
NUMBERS FROM LAST NIGHT THEY
WERE HISTORIC.
SOME PLACES SEEM TO DEFY
PHYSICS.
A LOT OF INFURIATED DEMOCRATS
NOT IN THE MOOD TO COMPROMISE.
THEY ARE APT TO BELIEVE ANYTHING
INCLUDING THAT JOE BIDEN CAN
BEAT SATAN AND SOLVE PERSONAL
PROBLEMS.
DON’T EXPECT BERNIE SANDERS TO
STAND IN THE WAY OF JOE BIDEN
NOT FOR LONG.
SANDERS PLAYS THE MAVERICK BUT
PRETTY CLEAR HE DOESN’T HAVE THE
STOMACH TO BUCK HIS OWN PARTY.
HILLARY CLINTON RIGGED THE DNC
FOUR YEARS AGO.
GAIN CAMPAIGNED FOR HER WHEN SHE
INEVITABLY WON THE NOMINATION.
JUST TODAY HOURS AFTER HE LOST
HIS FINAL CHANCE AT THE WHITE
HOUSE, SANDERS REFUSED TO CALL
JOE BIDEN WHAT HE IS, A
CORPORATE SHILL TASKED WITH
DRAGGING THE PARTY BACK TO 2009.
INSTEAD, SANDERS WENT OUT OF HIS
WAY TO PRAISE THE LONG-TIME
PUPPET OF THE CREDIT CARD
COMPANIES AS A MAN OF HIGH
CHARACTER.
>> AND I LIKE JOE.
JOE IS A DECENT GUY, AND I DO
NOT WANT THIS CAMPAIGN TO
DEGENERATE INTO A TRUMP-TYPE
EPIC WHERE WE ARE ATTACKING EACH
OTHER AND PERSONAL ATTACKS.
THAT IS THE LAST THING THIS
COUNTRY WANTS.
>> Tucker: YEAH, THAT’S NOT HOW
YOU GET ELECTED PRESIDENT AND IT
DOESN’T LOOK LIKE BERNIE WILL BE
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
LIKE SO MANY TRUE BELIEVERS,
SANDERS IS MORE COMFORTABLE
LOSING THAN WINNING.
IT’S HARD TO IMAGINE THROWING A
SCENE AT THE MILWAUKEE
CONVENTION TO PREVENT THE OBAMA
RESTORATION WHICH IS WHAT THIS
IS.
WITH BLOOMBERG OUT AND WARREN
HUMILIATED THERE IS NOTHING LEFT
IN AMERICAN POLITICS TO STOP JOE
BIDEN’S ASSENT TO THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINATION.
AND DOMINATION OF THE PARTY.
SO GET READY FOR JOE BIDEN.